c'est à trouver une solution pour nous
donner un peu d'air aux géants contraint
données qui me fait une proposition
un aviseur monsieur duval aura plus un
navire le poids face à puisque j'ai
gagné qui pour cent de tout on récupère
du combat lancé tous les mecs qui
passent par ici ou là où les yeux c'est
pas la vie vous devez envie de voir ça
c'est pas nous rêvons pas partie pour ça
désormais tout le monde fait dans la
drogue monsieur duo à ce que tu fais
c'est un signe de paix personne ne doit
savoir qu'il a travaillé on laisse pas
de trace j'ai plus confiance en toi mais
matip confiance en personne monsieur de
valve vous êtes un menteur et que vous
avez peur soit jamais complètement la
côte est où l'eau à la fin ça t'évitera
te faire massacrer
il faut que je suis dans une merde noire
visant la maison de trafiquants de
drogue c'est comme ça que tu prends soin
de ta famille
l'état attendait près d'une française je
travaille pour toi il est dangereux
match contre on peut aller quand tu
auras pas d'en tuer voile sur deux jours
avec moi tu as compris